he's an American computer programmer an
internet entrepreneur he's best known as
one of the cofounders of the social
networking website Facebook his personal
net worth is estimated to be thirty
eight point six billion dollars he's
Mark Zuckerberg and here are his top ten
rules for success first of all focus on
it right I mean I think like you
basically get what you spend your time
doing right I mean I want the company to
build three products this year and we're
gonna work on a few others because
people are interested in them but those
are the three things that I'm spending
my product time on right um
you get what you put into it if you
spend a third of your time trying to
make the people around you better
through getting better people mentoring
getting them to be better getting the
best people in your organization you're
known to more impactful roles than I
think over time not just a cruise and
you get a better organization we've had
this tradition for I don't know probably
seven or eight years at the company
where every week we have a QA where
where our employees can come and ask me
any question that they want about what's
going on and what the what the direction
of the company is or questions or things
that they read about in the press or
that their friends who use the product
what they're asking them and um it's
been this really important tradition for
us both because we really believe in an
openness and communication and that's
kind of what Facebook is all about but
it's also really important for for me
and for running the company to be able
to get feedback right and and to be able
to learn what's on people's minds what
our what our employees and folks who
were who were part of our team were
thinking about and just kind of a lot of
the time there are good questions that
people ask that changed the way that we
that we think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
and that often make us go think and
reevaluate how we should be approaching
different problems so many things go
wrong when you're starting a company and
often I think people ask you know what
mistakes
should you avoid making and you know my
answer the question is don't even bother
trying to avoid mistakes because you're
going to make tons of mistakes right and
the the important thing is actually
learning quickly from whatever mistakes
you make and
giving up right and I mean there are
things every single year of Facebook's
existence that could have killed us or
made it so that it just seemed like
moving forward and making a lot of
progress just seemed intractable but you
just kind of bounce back and you learn
and nothing is impossible you just have
to kind of keep running through the
walls
I don't hire people who I wouldn't work
for myself I know that's a really good
heuristic because ever knows this like
there's no saying like a player's hire a
players and B players hire C players
which is like good people hire good yeah
um and I don't think that that's that
informative right because I mean I'm
going to say like just so many
organizations are better B player you
don't get to hire people like I mean no
I mean um and I think a lot of the time
the problem is you don't actually know
and sometimes you're like trying to
figure out how good someone is if you
think they were good you wouldn't hire
them but the heuristic of only hiring
people who you would work for tends to
be pretty good I think because then it's
like then that you know right it's like
I would not work for this person then
okay I'm not gonna like stretch just
because I need to fill a role today when
you're starting something at some it's
just kind of hard you need to be pretty
headstrong about it or they're gonna be
all these challenges that come up and I
think the main thing that you need to do
is just not give up right and and kind
of know what you want to do and you know
the best entrepreneurs that who I've met
don't really start companies because
their goal is to build a company they do
it because they want to make a change in
the world and help people and I think if
you if you kind of stay true to that and
and if you just focus on kind of
powering through no matter what the the
challenges are that will inevitably come
up in your path then um you'll find that
there are lots of tools that are
available and a lot of people who will
help you build what you're building one
definition that I have for a good team
is a group of people that makes better
decisions as a whole than would
individually make is a sum of the parts
and when you're I think most smart
people like learning right and I mean
that's like one of the thrills of
starting a company right is you're just
that the learning curve can be so steep
and if you can set up a team dynamic
where you're constantly learning from
the people around you then I mean what's
better write these are the people I wake
up every morning and I want to I want to
go learn from and was from is that one
of your heuristics for hiring people to
to like hire people that you learn
yeah uh and when building a team you
want it to you want to think about the
dynamic so that way you can maintain
this property that the team makes better
decisions as a group than any individual
would I always kind of like I get a
little upset whenever any media
attention focuses on me personally and
me leading Facebook much less a movie
but it's been it's been kind of a bad
year as an admit it turned out ok time
got me it turned out it turned out ok
the time thing is awesome um the young
those those really flattering but like
but I think it's one of these things
that the media systematically gets wrong
is that this idea that it's a person
right it's never a person right it's
always a team and the most important
thing if you are an entrepreneur trying
to build something is you need to build
a really good team and that's what I
spend a lot of my time on right I mean I
spend probably at least three hours a
day with our core team right and doing
things I spend probably 25% of my time
recruiting finding good people both
outside the company and inside the
company to put in more in more impactful
roles so there's this inherent conflict
in the system though which is you know
are we trying to optimize newsfeed to
give each person all of you guys the
best experience when you're reading or
are we trying to help businesses just
reach as many people as possible and in
every decision that we make we optimize
for the first four making it so that
when for the people who we serve who use
Facebook into a reading newsfeed get the
very best experience that they can and
that means that if a business is sharing
content that's going to be useful for
them then we'll show that but that means
that if the business is sharing content
that isn't going to be useful for them
we may not show that because it's
probably more important that they
learned about their friend who had a
baby and their baby is healthy so that's
an important guiding principle for how
we think about this stuff
then as the as the products continue to
develop there is just going to be more
people sharing more things and we're
going to continue to try to do our best
at its showing the best things that we
can understanding that there's no way
that we can that a person will ever take
the time to go through every one of the
1,500 things
shared with them every single day so
that's but that's kind of how I think
about organic reach and um you know
there are a lot of pages that are going
that are doing quite successfully and
they're organic reaches is growing quite
a bit because they're delivering content
to people that they really want so if
you're a business owner and you're
thinking about how to use your free page
on Facebook I would just focus on trying
to publish really good content that's
going to be compelling to your customers
and the people who are following you you
know I actually I spend a bunch of time
analyzing and reflecting on why it was
that we were even able to do it because
oh like all reasons suggest that we
shouldn't have been able to do it right
because all these other companies had
way more engineering power and and and
servers and time and money and all this
stuff and I actually think that this is
a pretty instructive thing for anything
that you want to go do because this is
the same property is going to be true
for anything that you guys start is that
someone else is going to have more
resources and be able to do it the
reason why I think we actually ended up
being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else right so there were always
projects at some of these other
companies that were these hobbies but we
always thought that it was this really
important thing and really just like
felt in our gut in our heart that we
wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these skeptics saying
that oh this can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on but a lot of
the reason why bigger companies didn't
invest in it was because it wasn't clear
that there was a model that would work
for it it seemed like a bad idea yeah
and I actually think that that's true
for a lot of the best ideas where it is
that it's not that someone else can't do
it they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but I think often
that belief and the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day I mean one
of the the big emphasis points for the
company right now is Internet org and
you know for a while we had this
rallying cry of can we connect a billion
people and you know when we start
talking about that we thought that was
crazy right it was way bigger than any
service in the world that had been built
and you know it was ten digits long
right it's like a you know it just it
felt crazy we'd never get to that but
then the thing is as we've started to
actually get closer to that we took a
step back all right well
mission isn't actually to get one in
seven people in the world to be
connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the Internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early Facebook we don't there's no
business model around this I mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world I mean it's not necessarily a fair
thing are already the people who are on
Facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we were here to do this is what
our company cares about I care about it
the team cares about it our culture
cares about it so we're just going to
keep pushing on it and I actually think
a lot of the reason why great stuff gets
built is because it's kind of irrational
at the time but so it kind of selects
where the people who care the most about
it doing it but the students around me
were really important as well right and
both in high school and in college I
mean the people who started Facebook
with me and a lot of people who are
still with me running the company today
are people who I met when I was at
Harvard and some of them were mighty ups
at Harvard right and you know when the
professors were off writing papers these
were the people who actually taught me
and then we hung out and we had like
social bonds and academic bonds and I
just I wouldn't understate the
importance of that and I mean it's very
tied into my whole philosophy and the
product that that I spend my life
building Facebook because we just
believed that social bonds are critical
and um in one way that I think about the
the value that Facebook is filling in
the world is that you go through school
and at least when I did people just
focused on you know academics like
achievement different areas and one of
the things that no one really ever
taught me was like having friends is
really valuable no I'm not that I didn't
have friends but but like um although
you know the movie yes I could see that
um
but that first girlfriend is for sure I
don't think anyone is like it's not like
okay third grade we're going to like now
we're going to like teach you that like
hanging out with people is a very
important development right and I don't
know I actually think that that is and I
think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view Facebook as a
waste of time but I actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and I know that I wouldn't be where I
want where I am today without that
aspect of my life being as developed as
the academic part thank you so much for
watching
I made this video because mock certains
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I would also love
to know which of Mark Zuckerberg top 10
rules had the biggest meaning to you
leave it in the comments and I will join
in the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
hey everyone yesterday Governor Chris
Christie challenged me to the ALS ice
bucket challenge governor I accept your
challenge
and after I dumped this bucket of ice on
my head I get to nominate three new
people to challenge so I'm going to
challenge Bill Gates my partner at
Facebook Sheryl Sandberg and Netflix is
founder and CEO Reed Hastings to do this
within the next 24 hours so you have 24
hours to do this or you have to donate
$100 all right here we go
that was really cold I think that that's
why you become an entrepreneur right um
like you don't get to pick your partners
a lot of the time but you do get to pick
your organization and you do get to pick
who you partner with I mean sometimes
you may be forced by circumstances to
try to work with people who aren't your
top pick to have to work with but you
just like you get say over all this
stuff right and I don't know don't be a
victim make it happen but no I think the
real story is just you know a lot of
hard work right I mean it's a lot of
people who are engineers who kind of sit
around and code and and we're here
because we're trying to help people
connect and we believe deeply in this
mission and you know our community today
has 1.35 billion people in it and there
are seven billion people in the world
that we want to connect all of them and
that's why we're here